okay hello everyone it's Michael Vos
here and welcome to my order flows
market analysis from Friday February
10th
2017 uh before I jump in first brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
should not be considered a solicitation
a buy or sell a Future's contract or
make any other type of investment
decision Futures Trading contain
substantial risk and is not for every
investor an investor could potentially
lose all or more than the initial
investment risk capital is money that
can be lost without jeopardizing one's
Financial Security or lifestyle only
risk Capital should be used for trading
and only those with sufficient risk
Capital should consider trading past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future
results okay so
Friday February 10th you know it's kind
of an interesting day because you know
early on there were signs that we can
move higher and you know what are these
signs well after the cash open right
cash opens at
8:30 you know between 8:40 and you know
almost 9:00 8:40 to 850
we we ran this is a three ranging mini
chart and we started running up into the
highs we get the high have a Divergence
that's this little arrow here Arrow here
or Arrow here and you know within about
15 minutes we had you know four equal or
new highs you know this was a new high
here this one was the first new high and
then a new high here at 846 and then we
hit it again we equal the high we equal
the high and you've got the negative
Deltas so it's giving you the Divergence
so it's an
equal high or new high with the negative
Delta that's what the Divergence is and
with you know the down candle you know
where opened up here closed down here so
it's a red candle and usually right I
I've talked about this
before you know on days where the market
is going to you know Trend higher Trend
lower you'll often
get groups of imbalances not imbalances
um divergences rather and you know if
they happen you know in quick succession
like here you can see within 15 minutes
you got four already on this three range
chart to me that's a sign that you know
we could be bumping up higher uh a
little bit later in the session so you
know with that in mind you know I'll be
looking for some signs that we can
possibly go start to go
higher and you know after this fourth
Divergence here we we do come off a
little bit not much you know we go from
2310 down to uh 08 so about a two-point
move kind of go sideways we got point of
controls all in the same area there um
and here this is the price rejector
given a high and we start working our
way back up again now you know again am
I convinced yet that we're going to
break out through new highs not yet um
you know it has the signs we're still
hanging around the the high of the day
it's 9:30 pushing 920 um you know I want
to see more signs and then you know we
start to come off we come up within two
ticks of the high here come off we get
this stacked
imbalance you know which is encouraging
but you know when you're looking at the
numbers here I mean 146 12 44 those are
kind of pathetic numbers in in the sense
of you know look at some of these
numbers here when we're trading you know
2500 1200 1300 even when we're at the
high you know 4,000 here 1 1200 2900
1400 2,000 2,000 and and here you're
getting a stacked in balance with very
small number so I know that this bar mve
very quick so I'm not necessarily
convinced that you know hey this Market
all of a sudden picked up steam and it's
going to start to turn around and then
what happens it comes right back down
with a with the red candle here negative
Delta and we do go a little bit lower we
hit this area down here you know you got
some volume in here 1400 that's
encouraging and we start to work our way
back up and then we get up here right up
here near the
high and we get another stacked IM
balance this time the numbers are much
better here we had 146 121 443 here you
got 700 1500 1300 that's stronger you
know that's you know three or four times
stronger than what you had back here
I'll say it's more than that actually
but um you know at a minimum you know
400 against 1300 so you know this one is
is more encouraging than this one and
then the next bar right after it again
you still got the imbalances spilling
over you 379 2538 you know I always like
to get
imbalances when you're breaking through
new highs because you know that's a sign
that there's you know new buying coming
in um you know that that's going to help
move the market higher and you got a
ratio here you know this is a bullish
ratio so here you have you know the
Stacked in Balance I always say you know
look for the ratio afterwards and here
you get it in this bar a ratio of 45
it's a blue number which is what you
want to be looking at and you know we do
go higher hit this new high got a
Divergence again come off we hit another
new high again another Divergence so
again you're starting to hit these highs
getting divergences which is to me again
another sign that we can still go a
little bit higher you know we're still
hitting those highs you know on a
trending Market you're going to get a
lot of diver es and again you know don't
be taking every single Divergence and
you know getting short like on this day
because you'd have all these these
losing trades I mean sure you could get
short here and get a little something
but you know I I don't want to be you
know trying to scalp for a half a point
you know I'd rather be looking for you
know solid signs like this you know
where you got the you got the Stacked in
Balance you got the ratio afterwards and
then the market you know is giving you
the signs that we're going to go higher
I mean it does pull back down in here
here you get this stacked in
Balance negative but you know it just
goes sideways again it's a it's a
stacked selling imbalance which is
should be negative and you come right
back with a bullish ratio and you can
see we just spend the next four or five
bars inside there and here we hit the
new high you got a ratio we don't have a
Divergence you know still a nice
positive Delta here you got
Divergence and then you see that it's
starting to pick up again you we're
getting these imbalances again 2,800
2900 4,000
and you know these are strong numbers
and here you know we just keep going up
up up making these new highs again some
divergences and you know it would just
keep going higher um you again I'm not
going to say we're going to go higher
all the way to the close of the day I
think around uh you know around this
time is right around where we made our
high of the day but um you know the
signs were there early you know back at
8:40 this first whoops going back
here you this area in here 850 was a
early sign that you know we could be you
know we could be trending on this day we
could be going
higher which we did okay so the next
Market I want to talk about is the bonds
this is my bond it's a four range chart
okay and you know 7:00 in the morning
we're making new lows hitting these new
lows we have a Divergence with a ratio
which to me is a very bullish sign in
this case it's a buying um Divergence
and a bullish ratio but what happens
right in the next bar you know point of
control right at the top you've got a
bearish
ratio and you know the reason for taking
this trade is is gone already um I mean
you know you if if you're willing to you
could give it one more bar but honestly
you know when I get bullish sign has
followed up immediately with a bearish
sign I'm not that interested in staying
in the trade and then we get another
Divergence in the next bar
no no uh bullish ratio here just a
normal ratio and you know just going
sideways so again you know really quick
within 15 minutes you already got two um
two divergences okay that we've hit so
you know I'm I'm going to be watching to
see if we're going to make new lows and
we do again I'm not saying you know get
short because we got two divergences but
you know we got the first Divergence
which was a very bar uh bullish you know
with the ratio
afterwards Sor with the ratio in the bar
but then it's met with the bearish ratio
here so you know these two you know sort
of you know got a bullish ratio bearish
ratio I'm not going to say cancel each
other out but you know the reason for
getting along off this bar is is gone in
the next bar so you got two basically
two divergences which aren't necessarily
working out and then you get in 7:30 and
we just start trading lower we get
another Divergence down here at this
low this is the Delta surge given a buy
actually here this green but this is a
Divergence okay and there's no ratio and
honestly at this point I'm thinking hey
you know maybe we could start moving
higher we got a Divergence in this bar
we don't have a ratio but I always like
to look to the next bar to see if there
is a ratio and then you get one here and
you got the Delta surge you know given a
buy but this bar right here really
throws the monkey wrench in it because
it's you got a single print you've got a
bearish ratio right after two bullish
things so you know I'm a bit
hesitant and you you know as a result we
do come off a little bit lower make this
new low get another Divergence then you
got the same thing setting up
here more or less that you had earlier
here you've got the
Divergence and then in the next bar
you've got the bullish ratio with the
single print just like you have here you
got the Divergence and you got the
single print with the bullish ratio this
blue number okay but the problem is in
this bar it's negative all right you got
this bearish ratio with the single print
but here you just have a dogee so here
you've
got the Divergence You' got the ratio
afterwards and you know this one you
know is very similar here except you
don't have this bearish thing hanging
over and watch what happens you start
working your way up yeah you run into
this bar up here okay but you know it's
still still going higher this time the
Delta is a little bit smaller here it's
54 here he- 200 Watch What Happens the
next bar compared here we started coming
off- 200 negative Delta here minus a
th000
but here you got- 54 so it's it's it's
kind of weak you know and it comes right
back with the next bar positive Delta of
1427 so you know if you're sitting in
this bar and you're saying you know
you're not yet
convinced you know because you have this
even though you have bullish sign
bullish sign even here is kind of you
know this is nice to see you know that
we're going to start moving away from
this low then you get here with this
nice strong Delta that should be telling
you hey you know this Market is is ready
to start moving higher and you got a
couple nice solid imbalances in there 13
uh 700 400 and then you can see how it
just makes it start making its move um
you know higher over the next
uh you know the next few bars so you
know from around the 18 level we get all
the way up to you know 27 you know we do
come back down again to the uh 16 area
before mounting another another run
up this here is the Delta surge it just
sort of go sideways this time doesn't
really work out this I thought was kind
of interesting you've got the point of
control right on the bottom I always
like these bars where you have the point
of control either if it's green bar
right on the bottom or you know the red
bar that you saw earlier here right on
the top I this I find to be very bearish
in this case you know it did go down
before it turn around come back up and
then heading down but this
one you know this is this just stops the
move you know you can see you hit it
here the first time it traded 66 second
time 364 even went offered it traded 298
so it's um you know
2627 but the six is never trade and you
know people say well you got unfinished
business there look for it to come back
and I don't not even sure if it ever did
come back
there maybe later in the day um but you
know for now I'm looking as this as you
know some stopping activity in the
market and you can see I think it did
come back here let's take a look here
yeah I mean it came back at just before
1:00 traded four Lots then went through
it but you know for the short term
immediate term you know this level it
held it held nicely you know you could
have
got uh minimum of five ticks out of that
trade right there so you know watch for
those point of controls you know at the
bottom of the bars or at the top of bars
you know for a bottom for a green candle
and at the the top for a red candle okay
just real quick I was going to show you
a couple other charts these are the this
is the transition and this is a euro
currency it's a 987 tick chart and you
have a sell right here it did go down
come back up got you know probably what
stopped you out honestly it's a little
bit too too further past the entry point
for me um you know then again you know
just sort of hit up there then came off
um I think that would have stopped me
out I didn't trade that um I didn't
trade on Friday my
trading is has sort of been stopped for
now um I just got a lot of other things
going on even the trading room I've had
to uh stop for now I'll probably restart
it up in case you know I know people are
asking me you know they miss it but um I
just got so much on my plate right now I
need to take a break but you know later
in the day here you get a nice buy and
it's just straight up that was it on
this uh Euro currency there let me see
if I got another so I'm going go through
some other charts really quick
crude oil um this is what is
this this is the uh March crude 987 tick
chart I see nothing uh so you got a buy
here it does come right back down get
you know gets a little bit VI sort of
violates you know so you're getting
longer around 87 I mean come back down
you know maybe 10 ticks and then make
the move you know what can you do it
wasn't that great a day um on crude as
far as uh price movement you really
needed to be getting in earlier in that
day um even this day I didn't really sit
down in front of the charts until after
after
7:00 um let's take a look at what else
we got here euro currency I know there
was something I wanted to talk about
this is the uh you these are the
indicators there's several indicators on
this
chart again I'm just showing them on
this on these uh bar charts CU it's
easier to
see this is the U-turn actually here
this hash like
that and you know people have been
putting it on and
and you know trying to sort of figure
out you know what's a good setting you
know this is a setting of 3 and 25 I did
a video the other day last week of you
know what I think is some decent
settings that you could start with and
play around you know does it pick every
swing no you know here it picks okay
mean just going back to 8:00 here I
don't you know there's I mean we go back
earlier here I don't have it at 3: but
you know starting here does it pick this
low no does it pick this low yes does it
pick that high yes does it pick this
swing low yes um here these are kind of
equal then you know it picks this one
you know swing up to there swing to
there you know this one no doesn't work
out this one yes this one
no these kind of mix this one no this
one no this one yes this one double you
know recent double high again this a
eight range chart so you know each bar
is going to be you know nine ticks so
even if you get one or two bars out of a
move then you know that's that's good
already but you know it picks this swing
High down to this you know kind of Swing
Low where just goes sideways you know
then it picks the swing low um you know
some people want to pick every single
you know oh it has to pick this and this
I don't want this but you know sometimes
you know the market hasn't found its low
and it's still searching for its low
that's why you get these these little
moves like that in there
um just looking there's one other chart
I wanted to show you
guys maybe a couple let me give me a
second let me pull it up
here where is
it okay this is the transition this is a
eurocurrency one minute chart okay and
it's a settings of you know 3100 400
these are the settings I talk about in
that video and you know going back here
I mean again I didn't turn my system on
until about
7 look at this okay there's there's four
four three signals this day so you know
it's giving you a buy down here near
this
low and where is it here somewhere in
here okay so it's like 10625 and a half
and it does trade down to
21 Okay so you take a little bit of heat
okay so from five and a half down to 21
okay what is that nine ticks because
this trades in half ticks so you know
before that would be about five ticks
now it's you know nine ticks but look at
that are you willing to risk you know
five ticks 10 ticks here to catch a move
like this from you know from you know
call it
25 you know it trades up to 50 you know
it gets up here you know even to 40 okay
you know before it comes back down here
to 35 so you know say you took it all
the way up here and you took you said
I'm going to go higher you know I'm
going to be greedy and you take some
heat and it comes back down to 35 where
you cover it that's already 10 ticks
okay um then again here right this is a
little bit later you get this sell
signal up here it still hasn't quite
formed its high it's still forming the
high okay so again you know what the
transition does is you know it's looking
for these areas where the market is
moving from a supply driven Market to a
demand driven Market or vice versa in
this case we're in you know here we had
been going down so we're in a supply
driven Market you know Supply is driving
the market till demand comes in right
the market finds the demand here and
then it makes its move back up here okay
then it finds an area up here where it's
going to transition now from this was a
a demand driven Market because we're
going higher demand is driving the
market higher to a supply driven
market and you can see it right here and
we start come off here you know so again
it's a move from you know call it the 60
60 area 10660 area somewhere in here I
mean yeah you probably could have sold a
little bit higher but you know we'll
call it
60 and it makes it move down to 50 you
know even below actually gets down here
to to 40 I'm not going to say oh yeah
you would have covered it down here of
course not you'd probably be looking to
cover it somewhere after it makes this
big probe down and comes back honestly
you'd be looking to cover it somewhere
back in here 47
48 you know if you're trailing your stop
we get below 50 you should have a stop
at 50 and then you know so we work way
back up doesn't give a Buy Signal here
okay you know maybe it's not easily read
in the in the order flow okay I mean you
know these indicators yeah they pick
turning points but they're not going to
pick every single turning point you know
people expect you to be able to pick
every single Turning Point sometimes you
know the clues are not there in the
order flow um that's just the reality of
it but when it's there it's going to
pick it up okay and it picks it up again
here that we're moving back into a
supply driven market and you know if you
if you can get shorts somewhere in here
you'll call it 50 I don't know 57 58 you
know it goes back down to the 40s so
again you know it's that's it three
trades this day you know there's three
trades one two three from you know I
mean again you know I I didn't have my
system on this at 3:00 in the morning
but um you know when I had it on since
700 you know it it reads the data as it
comes in so don't install it on your
chart thinking it's going to plot on
historical data no it's got to read the
data as it's coming in that's what order
flow is about it's about reading the
trades that are coming in in real time
not about plotting them on historical um
data because that data isn't um doesn't
accurately reflect what the trading
that's going on so again three trades 1
two 3 okay and that's just a one minute
chart so you again I'll see if
there's anything else I do like to talk
about the mini
da I've become attracted to trading the
mini da
and I think it's a great contract
because especially now it's quite Vol
I'll say volatile but it moves around
much nicer I think than the snps and
this is again this the transition
indicator again you if you're trading
mini da wait till the cash open there's
no point in trading it in the pre-market
I mean you can but um it's best if you
just wait for the the cash
open and what I like about them this a
100 tick chart so it's you know it's and
mini da doesn't trade as much volume as
the uh as the e- minis but you know it's
it's still a decent contract and it gets
nice nice moves so this is the
transition this is 100 tick chart same
setting 4 three 100 400 okay so cash
opens at 830 you know we sort of go
sideways here here you get a sell it's a
little bit something here you get a buy
that fails here you start getting
another cell okay so you know maybe
you're getting in somewhere around you
know the 85 level and you know it trades
all the way down to the 70s then here
you get a nice buy here around the you
know 75 area be getting in here
somewhere in here makes a move back up
to the 90s so you know you get this move
down you get this move up this one
failed this one is is kind of crappy in
here it sort of gives you the buy then
comes back with the sell so you know
you're probably scrambling in there and
then you take a loss there you take a
loss on this one this one this one this
one well this one you know sort of go
sideways if it's going sideways after a
while chances are it's not going to
necessarily work out here again kind of
sideways on
you so yeah honestly you I mean you're
taking a few losses here so um you're
taking 1 2 3 4 5
six know maybe seven okay it's
discouraging I admit it is discouraging
you know but that's that's trading but
key is to take small losses and you know
what I mean by small losses
is you you're getting long in here in
this bar this is the signal bar but this
is the bar you'd be getting along at 97
you know maybe you got a A 7 tick 8 tick
10 tick stop okay so you know this one
you know probably wouldn't have stopped
you out and you could have gotten out
around broke even but you know you
should be having you should have a stop
in there whether it's five ticks you
know 10 ticks five ticks is kind of kind
of tight actually so you know get along
here at 06 five ticks would be down here
at uh 01 which is you know right here
okay you know it stops you out
but again you know what you want is to
have those tight stops five ticks 8
ticks 10 ticks even you know 10 ticks
would for me would be about as wide as I
go on this on this contract because you
want to stick around for this trade you
know so you're getting in at 95 trades
all the way up you know gets all the way
up to 30 um I'm not going to say 35 you
know but we'll call it uh you know we'll
call it easily
25 so from 95 to 25 is you know 30 ticks
okay so if if you're risking you know
six tick in here you know maybe some of
these you could have finessed and sort
of you know maybe broke even on or you
know take the full six tick loss you
know so you have 1 2 3 four five six
seven trades you know at minus 6
ticks know we call it seven ticks okay
so 7 * 7 is
49 this one just gave you 30 ticks right
there you take another trade in here
maybe you get something out of it we'll
call this one a scratch and then you get
this sell here you know so you're
getting short somewhere around uh you
know 43 4 you know call it 42 you know
right here but you know realistically
probably getting around 43 but we'll
call it 42 and it makes it move all the
way down to you know to 22 this is 22
here it actually just just sort of
stalls then gives you a buy here so
we'll call it 22 so that's 20 ticks so
that's 30 ticks you know on this move
earlier then 20 ticks that's 50 ticks
right there so you know you got back
what you lost right there and you know
you get another buy here which I don't
know if would have stopped you out but
also you got to take into account you
know these earlier
trades you know this trade that you had
here you know you could have had at
least you know from 88 down to you know
the
70s all right so and then you have this
trade here you know so this is about 15
20 ticks this trade here is um you know
from what you want to call it 73 up to
93 that's another 20 TI let's 40 ticks
right there um you know who knows what
you would have had in this but you know
the idea is to end the day ahead and you
know if you're catching you know if
you're just risking six seven eight
ticks a trade but you can see here
you're getting you know trades you know
20 30 ticks in profit you know that's
what you want everyone says oh you got
to have a 4 to1 risk reward ratio yeah
you'd like to have that reality is you
know often times you're just happy to
get you know come out of trade a tick
ahead at a minimum minimum um so again
you know this is this is the transition
indicator which you you can see on my
website but again you I'm showing you it
it suffered in here sometimes that's
what happens you know sometimes it runs
through these things these periods where
there's a lot of crap but it also picks
the nice Trends here like that I mean
and you saw the euro currency earlier
here okay it didn't chop you up in this
day was was you know the the textbook
beautiful day to trade and you know you
can't do anything
wrong
so you in short you know you know just
you know thanks for watching this you
know to learn more about these
indicators and orderflow you know I
think you know these indicators do work
with a bar chart they work with an
orderflow chart to get the most value
out of it you should be trading with an
orderflow chart um visit my website
order flows.com and you know learn more
about the
indicators and if you pick up the
software you know now you'll get the
indicators uh thrown in you know if
you're existing user uh you know just
shoot me an email if you're interested
in these indicators and you know you'll
get uh you know you'll get a discount on
them which basically just covers you
know some of my programming costs um so
again thanks for watching this and and
visit my website orderflows decom so
thank you and see you on the inside